la gastronomie est elle un instrument
d'influencé comme un autre assurément
pour le maire de romorantin la réponse
est oui
jeanny lorgeoux épinglé par mediapart ce
week-end pour ses frais de bouche plus
de 100000 euros d'argent public en trois
ans selon les factures épluché cette
fois par nos confrères de la nr les
repas étaient pris dans un restaurant
étoilé
pour le maire un outil de promotion de
la ville sébastien branger c'est une
bombe lancée par mediapart ce week-end
est reprise par la nouvelle république
le maire de romorantin aurait en effet
dépensé 100 de 1000 euros sur la période
2017-2020 en repas et nuitée dans un
établissement prestigieux de la commune
sur la base de ces informations
l'opposition crie donc au scandale moral
et invoque des pratiques certes légale
mais d'un autre temps la vraie question
c'est qu'est-ce qui rentre dans le cadre
des frais de bouche et dans le reste on
a les journées gastronomiques ils sont
intégrés dans le jumelage qui est
intégrée dans également moi une chose me
choque ce sont les montants quand on
voit les montants de certaines factures
de restaurant au vu du peu d'invités qui
est dessus
c'est totalement choquant pour moi les
élus doivent à l'heure actuelle est
beaucoup plus responsable de l'argent
public et c'est ce qui ce qui se passait
avant il ya un certain temps ne doit
plus exister aujourd'hui
quant à l'édile ils se défendent de tout
profit personnel et invoque l'intérêt
pour sa ville de recevoir des
personnalités dans les meilleures
conditions
pour lui ces révélations sont donc ourdi
par son opposition
l'attachement que j'ai un développement
de ma ville dans lequel je vis
m'autorise à dire que ce sont des
vilenies et des baffes qui sont
actuellement produites cet acharnement
ma perte alors que je ne vais plus me
représenter à aucune élection dont le
futur est le signe d'un affolement de
jeunes qui ne peuvent pas respecter leur
venin qui veulent tout tout de suite
un audit sur les frais de représentation
du maire a ainsi été demandé par
l'opposition municipale
la demande devrait être formalisé lors
du prochain conseil
et puis on vient de l'apprendre le
au coeur de la république de blois
frédéric chevalier ouvre une enquête sur
cette affaire afin de vérifier la
légalité de ces dépenses de repas